in 2021 the price of a single bitcoin
the leading cryptocurrency broke 60 000
[Music]
and the market value of all
cryptocurrencies reached a staggering
2.5 trillion dollars bitcoin's promise
to create a new decentralized financial
system
beyond the control of governments and
banks has captured the imagination of
the world
it's become a bit of a social phenomenon
mark zuckerberg the boss of facebook
has pet goats and he's named them max
and bitcoin
but so far the bitcoin dream has not
been realized
[Music]
rather than becoming a new form of money
bitcoin has become a highly volatile
investment asset creating big winners
investors have said its price
skyrocketing during the pandemic
and big losers the crypto valuation
lost a third of a trillion dollars just
overnight
for the believers bitcoin is still a
digital stepping stone towards a utopian
future
for the skeptics the crypto market is
nothing more than a digital casino
too volatile to be trusted
so what will become of the bitcoin dream
[Music]
it all started in 2009 somewhere in the
world
a shadowy figure hiding behind the name
of satoshi nakamoto
created the very first bitcoin
it was the start of a digital revolution
bitcoin and the thousands of
cryptocurrencies that have followed
are nothing like actual coins they are
code
recorded on a digital ledger that gets
longer and longer as more people use
them
and embedded in nakamoto's code for the
first batch or block of bitcoins
was a newspaper headline bitcoin's
creator put that headline in the first
block
because he wanted to send a signal he
wanted to show that people were looking
for alternatives after the financial
crash
and the question that people were asking
is can we trust
financial institutions with our money
and bitcoin was the response
trust is at the heart of the current
financial system banks and other
financial institutions
control how money flows around the
economy
faith that their ledgers are accurate is
vital
this is because money is simply a social
convention
it exists and has value because we agree
that it does
this agreement only works because we put
trust in financial institutions
such as banks bitcoin does not require
trusted institutions nakamoto
wanted to create a secure system that
did not rely on any trust at all
to achieve this the coins are registered
on a revolutionary technology
called a blockchain which is a ledger of
transactions
that is not held by a centralized
institution
instead transactions are verified and
logged by a network of computers
all over the world in a process known as
mining
we're combining this for two purposes
one is to put new bitcoin in circulation
and the second one which is also
essential is to verify transactions on
the network
[Music]
but it's a complex process if someone
wants to make a transaction
everyone on the network is alerted the
transactions are verified by so-called
miners first they check the transactions
are legitimate
once a miner has checked a few thousand
transactions
they group them together in a block
that's the easy part the miners then
race for the right
to add this block to a string of those
previously made
known as the blockchain to do this they
compete to solve a complex numerical
problem
the miner that solves it first sees
their block added to the chain
and they are rewarded in bitcoin this
whole process
is incredibly energy intensive and is
contributing to the climate crisis
as of may 2021 bitcoin mining used more
electricity annually
than the whole of the netherlands to
keep bitcoin scarce
and to help maintain its value the
number of bitcoins that can be
mined is capped at 21 million
to date almost 19 million bitcoins have
been mined
but it cannot yet be classified as money
for something to be considered money it
has to work in three ways
as a medium of exchange as a store of
value
and as a unit of account for
all the main functions of money that you
can think of actually so far bitcoin is
not superior to the
solutions that we already have which are
shared money and
other ways of paying and that's you know
the main reason why
it you can't really call it the currency
now
here's why fundamentally bitcoin is a
string of code with limited use
like a gold bar it doesn't produce any
revenue
but compared with the price of gold the
value of a single bitcoin is hugely
volatile
and a single tweet can change people's
faith in it as a future currency
as a result its price moves wildly up
and down as people buy and sell it
and unlike the dollar there's no central
bank or government to defend its value
this volatility also makes bitcoin very
hard to use as a medium of exchange
so a seller on amazon is unlikely to
accept bitcoin for their goods
as the following day the price could
vary dramatically
as happened on may 19 2021
the price dropped almost 8 000 in less
than an hour
but that's not stopping el salvador the
central american country has become the
first to adopt bitcoin as legal tender
it's a major gamble bitcoin doesn't
really work as a means of payment
because it's very inefficient
it can process only 10 transactions per
second
when you know visa the credit card
company can do as much as
24 000 per second so if bitcoin doesn't
work as a way of paying for things
what gives it value like shares and
bonds
it's also traded as an investment this
has led to a speculative mania
where teenagers have become millionaires
it's not just
a maybe a get-rich-quick scheme as a lot
of people put it but i
see it as the future of currency and
others
have lost it all literally in 2013
one unlucky man in wales even scoured a
rubbish dump for a hard drive containing
7500
accidentally discarded bitcoins without
that
file there is no way of getting the
money back because there is no central
um
central server that records a log of it
today that hard drive would be worth 218
million dollars
if only he could find it
but investing in cryptocurrency is no
longer for early adopters and armchair
investors
it's attracting attention from some of
the world's biggest banks
including morgan stanley which now
offers investors access to bitcoin funds
but even cautious buy-in from some
financiers brings greater scrutiny
banks are taking tentative steps to get
into bitcoin
regulators are watching this closely and
so far they've only allowed a limited
set
of things that banks can do they can
provide access to the market to clients
but they can't bet on the market
themselves for example using their own
capital
and regulators are also wary because
bitcoin has a dark side
[Music]
so bitcoin has been used to fund
criminality or to launder money
uh if you venture on the dark web for
example which i did
for an article recently you'll find that
everything from
stolen credit card details to to drugs
is priced in bitcoin there's
has also been a lot of theft from crypto
exchanges
and a lot of fraud and it's not just
criminality that is ringing alarm bells
leading economists have warned that
bitcoin is a dangerous bubble
destined to burst and join the graveyard
of historically hyped-up
investments like the tulip mania of the
1630s
where the price of tulip bulbs rose
sharply before spectacularly crashing
or the dot-com boom in the late 1990s
in 2018 there was reason to believe the
skeptics
might be right the sharp surge and later
drop
in the price of bitcoin mimicked these
historic bubbles
a pattern which continued into the first
half of 2021
the price soared to over 60 thousand
dollars
only to fall again the bitcoin market is
very fragile in 2020 and 2021
we've seen these students you know sharp
drops in in price
on the basis of very little and then
they partially recover for
you know other bits of news that that
are completely unpredictable
supporters see cryptocurrency as a
burgeoning asset class with real value
more like gold than tulips but the jury
is still
out on whether the comparison is
accurate bitcoin
or another cryptocurrency might become
you know relatively
stable or trusted asset class like gold
but it's too early to tell
because you can see today as soon as
people think it's no longer a good
investment
then dumb and plummets and value with it
perhaps the biggest winner from its
climb
is bitcoin's mysterious inventor satoshi
nakamoto
assuming of course that nakamoto is a
real person who is still alive
they're thought to own more than 1
million bitcoin
currently worth around 37 billion
dollars
bitcoin may yet become a stable asset
like gold
or prove to be a bubble that bursts
spectacularly
but one thing is for certain the utopian
dream
of bitcoin becoming a new form of money
beyond the control of governments and
central banks
is still as elusive as the technologies
creator
[Music]
i'm matthew favaz finance correspondent
at the economist to read more for
coverage on bitcoin please click on the
link
thank you for watching